for weeks we've been sharing stories of
coronavirus hot spots in the south but
communities in other parts of the
country including the pacific northwest
they're suffering too amid this latest
surge
hospitalizations in oregon hit a record
high yesterday icu beds are at 93
percent capacity statewide oregon's
governor has now deployed national guard
members to more than 20 hospitals and
many health systems have canceled
elective surgeries the staff at asante
rogue regional medical center invited
our janet's family inside to see the
heartache for the staff and their
families
visitors aren't allowed in the icu and
yet three of the 15 rooms here have
family members in them right now they're
not here for a visit they're here for a
last visit to say goodbye
there's constant turnover in this
medford oregon intensive care unit but
not because patients are getting better
how bad is it right now i mean every day
we see just
the body boxes roll out
one after the other
and then as soon as we clean the room we
get somebody back in there
it's it's the worst we've ever seen icu
nurse clarissa carson says relatives
used to be able to stay in these rooms
to grieve after loved ones passed as
long as they wanted
now they have to be out in less than an
hour so another covid patient waiting
down the hall can get in there's only
one icu bed available in the entire
region we have patients waiting to get
onto life support there's no escaping
the anguish
as we were listening to icu doctor
samnath gauche the tone around is so
rapid it's
it's pretty sad as i'm talking to you
doctor
what you can't see is that we can hear
family members coming out of a room and
they are crying because
why because we withdrew life support and
chances are they just passed
these patients are on such tremendous
levels of life support once we
stop that they last less than a few
minutes suffering and sorrow are now
part of every day i've never seen so
much death in my career we're surrounded
by it icu manager kelsey robinson is
frustrated by vaccine hesitancy
just last night hundreds protested
vaccines outside the hospital many who
said they were hospital staffers our
community is getting ripped apart by
the people who don't believe in the
vaccine the people who do
most in this intensive care are
unvaccinated every patient except one is
on a ventilator they are so sick nurse
carson says the odds are against
survival the grief is tremendous we are
used to winning
us icu nurses are we're used to winning
and we're not winning
we're losing
and there will be more loss what some
are calling collateral deaths dr gauche
tells me they have put off more than 100
heart surgeries over the past two months
because there is simply no room for
those patients here no resources
some of those patients he says will
likely die
anthony just a devastating story janet
thank you very much